[Musique]
turbo de Fabergé la Formule 1 de nos
toilettes
[Musique]
et c'est parti pour un tour où les
jeunesse
[Musique]
on ne joue pas avec la vie
quand on jette une boîte ou une
bouteille sans le savoir on s'allie la
France alors
j'ai eu des fleurs
et pourtant c'est si simple cette année
encore des millions de sacs poubelles
sont mises à votre disposition mais si
vous ne faites pas un tout petit effort
ces grands efforts ne servent à rien
gardez la France propre agence nationale
pour la récupération et l'élimination
des déchets
il faut un verre de lait comme celui-ci
pour faire une portion de fromage
samousse 99 alors chaque fois que à
chaque fois que votre enfant mange une
portion de sa mousse 99 il prend 38 mg
du calcium nécessaire chaque jour à sa
croissance et à son équilibre
ça monte 99
c'était en janvier 34 dans
l'Orient-Express que j'allais rencontrer
celle que je ne devais jamais plus
oublier
[Musique]
de celle que j'appelais l'Oriental il ne
me resterait désormais qu'une image et
un parfum
l'Oriental un parfum inoubliable
[Musique]
à l'infini
[Applaudissements]
depuis toujours l'homme a cherché la
meilleure solution pour mieux se raser
aujourd'hui il utilise chic pivot sa
tête pivotante reste en contact
permanent avec la peau son bouton
rinclam le garde toujours propre chic
pivot va plus loin pour vous raser le
prêt bonjour Sylvania est expert en
poule
Sylvania est expert en poule
[Musique]
c'est trop
c'est Tropico
si vous savez descendre cet escalier
avec la paire vous saurez le monter la
paire il y en
a pas ça va
vas-y
vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y
vas-y vas-y vas-y 100% farine complète
moi je connais un fromage moelleux
savoureux c'est le chaussé au mois
chaussée au moins
j'ai 8 secondes pour vous dire que
là-bas revoiles c'est de la dynamique
qui était tique de l'effort et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater le Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu